[Música]
[Aplausos]
esta foto fue tomada el 17 de junio del
año 2007 en indianápolis en una carrera
de fórmula 1 el piloto invisible no se
ve es sebastian vettel cuatro veces
campeón del mundo después de esta
carrera
lo importante de esta foto para mí es
que justamente no es una foto comercial
sino que fue tomada por un rafaelino
compañero de trabajo que el día en
agosto del 2008 que a mí me designaron
gerente general de la empresa donde
estoy hoy el vino y me la regaló como
una forma de identificar un modelo de
liderazgo
y mi sorpresa fue que coincidía con una
aspiración al mío desde el momento que
comencé a liderar personas un líder casi
invisible e imperceptible y un equipo
sincronizado de tal manera que pueda
lograr grandes resultados saben una cosa
esta misma foto la obs el día que di la
primera charla con mi equipo de trabajo
cuando me dieron la designación
yo 35 años en mi vida
liderando personas en el ámbito
particular en el ámbito profesional y
bien dije personas porque claramente a
veces es solamente liderado personas y
otras veces logré formar equipos de
trabajo
hay algo que a lo largo de estos años me
ha inquietado me ha preocupado a veces
angustiado a veces movilizado pero que
siempre produce algo en mi es una
pregunta recurrente permanente que llevo
dentro mío
en tantos años he trabajado con la gente
he alcanzado a conocer lo que somos como
país el potencial que tenemos el talento
que tenemos y la pregunta es por qué
llevamos décadas
casi seis décadas de fracasos
porque tantos años de no hacer de
nosotros mismos algo sustentable en el
tiempo y proyectado en el tiempo porque
no lo hemos logrado
cuál es la respuesta a tantas décadas de
fracasos constantes independientemente
del color político del plan económico y
también independientemente de los
pensamientos personales
la respuesta que me dado a mí mismo y de
la cual estoy convencido y por eso
quiero hablarles en este día
la raíz de todos nuestros males está en
el modelo de liderazgo
un modelo individualista
un modelo sin valores
un modelo cortoplacista que nos ha
llevado a reiterar errores
por lo cual
en el aprendizaje con tanto que
constante que me ha tocado desarrollar
aprendí que hay algunas cuestiones que
son innegociables en el liderazgo y fui
armando como mi propio decálogo
para poder claramente tener un camino un
recorrido el primero de ellos que tuve
que aprender
es
que sin resultados no hay recompensas
esto no quiere decir que esté bien o que
esté mal es una realidad es un dato de
la realidad
sabes seguramente en cualquier momento
que te toque liderar un proyecto o lo
que fuere te vas a encontrar con
reconocimientos
te vas a encontrar con valorizaciones de
cosas que hiciste pero la recompensa
solamente va a venir si hay resultados
tenemos un ejemplo contemporáneo actual
gráfico se llama lionel messi
es el mejor jugador del mundo
recompensado reconocido
indiscutible en europa en españa - a
dónde
en la argentina
porque porque nunca logró resultados con
la selección argentina
sin resultados lamentablemente no hay
recompensas el segundo punto pensando en
los resultados que se ha transformado
como parte de una convicción personal yo
lo denomino como el fin no justifica los
medios
sabes algo cuando logramos objetivos sin
tener en cuenta los medios sin respetar
valores cuando vamos detrás de objetivos
cortoplacistas
vamos a tener resultados de muy corto
plazo
y lo que estamos necesitando es un
liderazgo que trascienda en el tiempo se
muestre como algo que nos marque para
transformar una sociedad como la nuestra
podemos tener líderes de distintas
características que han logrado
resultados de distintos tenores pero
cuando vos miras a aquellos que
trascendieron en el tiempo vas a ver
personas como nelson mandela en
sudáfrica como martin luther king en
eeuu como mahatma gandhi en india o como
el propio favaloro en argentina lograron
sus objetivos pero para ellos el qué
no era independiente del cómo
sino que cada una de las cosas que
hicieron la hicieron sostenidas sobre
valores
el tercer punto en mi decálogo es el
foco
cuando líderes muchos están tentados
a enfocarse en los resultados y yo estoy
convencido que un liderazgo
transformador es aquel que se enfoca en
las personas que generan los resultados
cuando te enfocas en los resultados
solamente te enfocas en tus resultados
en tus objetivos en tus necesidades
te vuelves individualista egoísta cuando
te enfocas en las personas te enfocas en
los intereses comunes en los resultados
consensuados
y claramente es la única forma de formar
parte de un equipo
entonces este modelo de liderazgo que
necesitamos que claramente necesita
resultados pero no a cualquier precio y
orientado a las personas demanda de
valores
si nosotros queremos transformar una
sociedad tenemos que comenzar a
transformar nuestro liderazgo para
transformar en un liderazgo que busque
resultados fundados sobre valores y
enfocado en las personas hay tres
valores que son insustituibles
que no se pueden reemplazar que son
necesarios el primero de ellos se llama
integridad
sabes la integridad no es solamente ser
honesto o no ser honesto la integridad
no es solamente robar o no robar la
integridad es mucho más que eso
es tener valores es ser confiable es ser
leal es no mentir es ser de una sola
palabra
y tratar de mostrar y de hacer las cosas
correctas hacer las cosas que
corresponden muchas veces vas a tener
que tomar decisiones que no son seguras
ni populares ni políticas mente correcta
pero son las que corresponden y cuando
tomas las decisiones que corresponden
van a generar en aquellos a quien líder
az una palabrita maravillosa que se
llama confianza sin integridad puede
haber resultados de corto plazo pero no
vas a generar confianza nuestros líderes
necesitan ser íntegros para generar
confianza les quiero contar una anécdota
que me pasó en forma personal porque la
quiero contar porque fue la decisión
quizás desde lo profesional más
trascendente de mi vida
corría el año 1986 yo trabajaba en una
empresa en la ciudad de santafé
y venía en un proyecto interno que venía
proyectando con muchas posibilidades
siempre fue una persona que trato de
vivir los valores adecuadamente y me
resistí a hacer lo incorrecto para
lograr algún objetivo particular
y no voy a olvidar nunca una tarde
cuando yo venía caminando por una
galería y me encuentro con el gerente
general una persona que me apreciaba
mucho que teníamos mucha empatía desde
lo comercial y desde lo que era el
negocio y él apoyó su mano en mi hombro
casi paternalistamente para decirme
rodolfo en esta empresa tenés mucho
futuro pero sabes algo te quiero
compartir que pienso que tus valores no
coinciden con los valores de los
negocios
fue como si un puñal se me clavar a
en lo más hondo
y cuando volví a mi casa casi sin haber
dado respuesta al momento recuerdo que
con mi señora que está acá compartiendo
conmigo yo le dije creo que termino un
ciclo
había que tomar una decisión
y quizás
venía acompañada de riesgos
pero era hacer lo correcto y cuatro
meses después estaba trabajando en la
empresa
si vos querés generar confianza tenés
que ser íntegro
la integridad genera confianza
pero el segundo valor no solamente
refiere a la integridad sino que es
complementario y tiene que ver con la
empatía
qué es la empatía la empatía es aprender
a ponerte en el lugar del otro
el aprender a compartir a entender para
poder sacar lo mejor de cada uno
es saber lo que está pensando lo que
sufre lo que necesita para que su
talento a flórez y poder ver frutos
miren en la presentación fue más que
elocuente que no soy hincha de boca
pero claramente tengo una admiración por
este señor
carlos bianchi siempre me llamó la
atención por cómo manejaba sus equipos y
cada vez que escuchaba un testimonio de
algún jugador que formó parte de su
plantel yo escuchaba los halagos a él
por la forma en que lo manejaba
entonces un día hace algunos años atrás
siendo entrenador de boca me entero que
daba una conferencia en buenos aires y
allí me anoté y allí fue con muchas
expectativas y carlos tenía una forma de
manejarse muy particular no era un
discurso y sta una persona que
presentaba un discurso preparado él le
gustaba sentarse en un escritorio y
decía pregunten entonces la gente del
lugar preguntaba
y me acuerdo que alguien le dijo como
haces
para poder conformar equipos entre tanta
gente entre tantos egos
entre tantas particularidades y él
respondió empatía
es conocer a cada uno
saber interpretarlo y dijo algo por eso
la foto de los tres yo no le puedo dar
el mismo mensaje a juan ramón que al
mellizo que a palermo tengo que
conocerlos
tengo que saber sus necesidades tengo
que conocer cómo lo voy a potenciar y a
partir de eso y agramar el discurso para
trabajar con él sin empatía es imposible
conformar equipos
es imposible
y claramente carlos tenía esta
particularidad
la particularidad de saber trabajar con
las personas independientemente de todo
su conocimiento técnico de saber ponerse
en el lugar del otro necesitamos líderes
que se enfoquen empáticamente en las
personas
el tercer valor es un valor que sé que a
todos nosotros que somos de esta región
nos cuesta mucho asumirlo
su valor
se llama generosidad
nos cuesta desprendernos de nosotros
es generosidad
generosidad es dar al otro más de lo que
el otro está esperando hay una foto que
a mí me encantó ponerla ilustra esto
quizás ese chico estaba esperando una
limosna pero la persona que lo atendió
se despojó de su sandalia de lo que
tenía y lo puso al servicio del otro eso
se llama generosidad
sabes algo el libro que más impacto mi
vida es la biblia
y la biblia tiene un párrafo que a mí me
impactó desde el día en que lo leí
es mejor dar que recibir
y cuando uno lo verbaliza es una cosa
pero cuando lo tiene que vivir es otra
necesitamos líderes generosos generosos
desde el punto de vista de disponer de
tiempo para las personas generosos para
dar reconocimientos a aquellos que se lo
merecen generosos para desprenderse en
recompensa para aquellos que hicieron
bien las cosas la generosidad es una
gran fuente de compromiso y motivación
de la gente
la generosidad es algo que tenemos que
aprender a incorporarlo como parte de
nosotros estoy en contra del concepto de
que el silencio es señal de aprobación
necesitamos reconocer necesitamos
dedicar tiempo por el otro
necesitamos recompensar a aquellos que
son los que hacen el trabajo los que
forman parte del equipo
cerrando el tema
y si tendríamos que hablar de un
diagnóstico te diría que el nuestro es
un problema de valores
nos cuesta transformar nuestro liderazgo
en función de valores pero quiero
decirte algo si vos son jazz conmigo en
la transformación va a venir por líderes
transformados líderes que buscan
resultados que no solamente le importa
el qué sino el cómo por el cual el fin
no justifica los medios y que están
enfocados en las personas
solamente con integridad con empatía
y con generosidad lo vamos a lograr
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]